congress is set to pass president
biden's giant and we do mean giant
coronavirus relief package
in the next few hours the 1.9 trillion
dollar bill
has something in it for almost every
american family in fact most people are
going to benefit from this including
larger child tax credits and other
measures intended to give
long-term boosts to low-income americans
nicole killian is on capitol hill for us
nicole good morning to you
there's a lot of people waiting for this
bill yeah absolutely tony and millions
of americans will
benefit from this piece of legislation
with direct stimulus payments expected
to go out
later this month it'll be the
president's first legislative victory
after the house cleared one last
procedural step last night
i'm so excited i just can't hide it the
1.9 trillion dollar coveted relief
measure has broad support from democrats
but no republicans
let's help families who are struggling
with a targeted relief bill not just
sending everybody a check
all across america regardless of the
political battle single mom sarah mealy
says it's a check that
will provide much needed relief things
are tight right now
and
yeah it's been very difficult sarah and
others making under 75 thousand dollars
a year will receive fourteen hundred
dollars
couples who make under 150 000 will get
twenty eight hundred
it phases out for people who make
slightly more
it's gonna help us with my bills it's
gonna help me pay down
my credit card debt it's gonna help me
uh
pay for my car insurance and my renters
insurance
and just you know afford rent too
the bill also extends unemployment
benefits at 300 dollars a week
provides aid to reopen schools increase
vaccine distribution
and support state and local government
and it includes a tax credit for parents
of
up to 3 600 dollars per child every
50 dollars that comes in every twenty
dollars
makes a big difference and i know a lot
of people
are also feeling that way
democrats say this is the biggest piece
of legislation
since the affordable care act they
believe by spending bigot will lead to
economic recovery but by going it alone
republicans accuse the president
of breaking his promise of
bipartisanship he will highlight the
plan in a prime time address
tomorrow anthony so many folks like
sarah maylie need those checks nicole
thank you